bataille sur un troisième allez ça
tourne bajoues benkan entre en scène
d'ajouts c'est le personnage
qu'interprète boujenah dans le nouveau
film d'ariel zeitoun le nombril du monde
un boujenah déformé par les kilos
prothèse dentaire pour contrer les joues
double menton et ventre en plastique pas
les clés soit 3 je rêvais mois-là
personnages extrêmement gros parce que
je voulais qu au départ ce personnage
est une différence obligatoirement un
handicap mais qu'il ya une différence
évidente avec les autres sur le ventre
de michel scène et tirano c'est ce qui
fait sa distante avec les autres dans la
tunisie de contact aura français jusqu'à
celle de l'indépendance le nombril du
monde raconte l'irrésistible ascension
de ce badge houben ken juif tunisien né
pauvre petit et gros un personnage
cynique prêt à tout pour réussir qui
fait de sa vie un jeu dont ils truquent
les règles à son unique profit
à nous deux
et moi je compte pour du beurre
[Musique]
d'accord voilà ils ont aussi la loire
qui avoue un vieux film qu'avec boujenah
ce rastignac du bled ça devait être
normal je tenais énormément à lui vit
parce que je pensais que c'était
quasiment le seul comédien avec lequel
je pouvais communiquer sans s'en moque à
venir simplement par ce n'est pas par
par souvenirs interposé par tibre comme
ça c'est on sait exactement de quoi on
parle sans en parler entre eux il y à la
mémoire de la terre natale la première
fois que je les ai vus j'ai compris que
pour elle j'étais prêt à tout
est ce qu'on peut corriger comme à vous
aimer la vie ne m'avait pas encore
appris
[Musique]
ma joue avec brio ce monstre d'orgueil
et des gaullistes à la fois pour les
victimes
il réussit à faire en sorte qu'on le
déteste jamais vraiment
[Musique]